Traduttore: Riccardo Fraccaro
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Con questa frase,
Botero spiega esattamente
quello di cui noi vogliamo parlarvi oggi,
ossia di come per noi il confrontarsi
sia diventato un modo
per moltiplicare le opportunità.
Ma facciamo un passo indietro,
scommetto che sicuramente
chiunque di voi si è sentito chiedere
da piccolo: "Cosa vuoi fare da grande?"
Tu, Margherita, cosa rispondevi?
Beh, io a sei anni
volevo fare la ballerina
e, infatti, 20 anni dopo,
sono un ingegnere.
Coerente devo dire.
Perché tu vorresti dirmi che già a sei
anni volevi fare la designer?
No, hai ragione, in realtà, volevo fare
la cuoca, ma poi ho cambiato idea.
Forse perché la cucina
non era la mia unica passione,
mi piaceva anche la storia,
il cinema,
ma anche inventare e realizzare
con le mie mani giochi e oggetti nuovi,
e per questo ho studiato design.
E com'è che tu sei finita
a ingegneria dei materiali?
Beh, mi è sempre piaciuta
l'idea di progettare qualcosa utilizzando
la matematica, che è sempre stata
un po' la mia passione.
Però, nel momento in cui
mi sono trovata a sfogliare quelle guide
in cui descrivono tutte
le ingegnerie disponibili,
mi sono anche trovata davanti
questo corso in cui spiegavano
come produrre i materiali
e come utilizzarli al meglio.
E, in realtà, è solo
dopo questi 5 anni di università
che mi sono trovata davanti
alla scelta di cosa fare veramente
del mio futuro e,
spinta dalla voglia di continuare
a sperimentare in laboratorio,
ho deciso di continuare
con un dottorato di ricerca.
Ed è proprio da qui,
il punto da cui vogliamo partire oggi.
Dopo qualche giorno dall'inizio
di questo dottorato,
mi viene comunicato che durante
tutto il percorso avrei dovuto collaborare
con una seconda persona: un designer.
Si, adesso vi chiederete
perché tutta questa perplessità,
pero' nella mente di un ingegnere,
come mi immaginavo io un designer?
Così.
Quindi, capite, insomma,
un creativo che magari utilizza
i tavoli come sedie e le sedie come tavoli
e che utilizza tutto il tempo
durante il giorno a disegnare bozzetti
di cose che nella maggior parte dei casi
non verranno mai realizzate.
Grazie comunque.
Prego.
Ma, tornando a noi,
inizia ad esserci un via vai di pensieri
e di domande nella mia mente:
la prima che mi faccio è:
"Ma cosa faccio se un giorno mi arriva
con un bozzetto,
magari costituito da due linee veloci,
e mi chiede di realizzare
quello che vedo?".
O peggio ancora,
se mi fermasse per ore e ore
a discutere del tono
di colore troppo o troppo poco brillante.
Mi rendo conto, in quel punto,
che avrei avuto ben poco in comune
con questa seconda persona.
Come potete immaginare,
questo designer, sono io
e, diciamo, puoi confermarlo anche a loro,
che finora non ti ho mai presentato
alcun bozzetto da esaminare.
Sono infatti una designer atipica,
invece che passare il mio tempo
a disegnare o a inventare nuovi progetti,
seleziono materiali
per dar forma a nuovi prodotti.
È un po' come entrare
in una cabina armadio
e scegliere quale vestito mettere
per una determinata occasione,
ma fin dall'università ci viene insegnato
che in questo processo di scelta
non siamo i soli,
in realtà veniamo spesso supportati
da alcune figure piuttosto singolari,
di sesso maschile prevalentemente,
che cercheranno di metterti
in difficoltà sempre con domande tecniche
e possibilmente legate
a formule matematiche.
Chi sono? Gli ingegneri.
A me è capitata lei, e devo ammettere
che anche io all'inizio del dottorato
ho avuto qualche pensiero e la paura
di essere continuamente interrogata
sulla tavola periodica,
quindi non sapendo bene come iniziare
questo dialogo, abbiamo iniziato
a confrontarci su una conoscenza
che avevamo in comune: lui.
Lui, no, non è il nonno
di nessuna delle due,
nessun parente in comune,
lui è il professor Michael Ashby
dell'Università di Cambridge,
ed è l'autore di numerosi testi
su cui entrambe abbiamo studiato
materiali, ma è anche il primo
che ha capito che combinare
il punto di vista di designer e ingegnere,
permette di ampliare la conoscenza
sui materiali che ci circondano.
In realtà, è proprio collaborando
su questo argomento,
che abbiamo capito come unire
diverse prospettive
di una stessa disciplina o
di uno stesso oggetto sia molto più utile
perché ci aiuta a moltiplicare
le informazioni a noi in possesso e,
soprattutto, a capire veramente
di cosa stiamo parlando.
Ma, capisco che è un concetto
un po' complesso da spiegare,
quindi vorremmo cercare di chiarirlo
con un esempio molto molto semplice.
Partiamo da questa immagine,
cosa vedete in questa foto?
Senza dubbio, una mela rossa.
Confermo.
Ma, cosa sarebbe successo,
se l'avessimo vista
esattamente dalla parte opposta?
Avremmo visto questo.
Quindi è solamente quando uniamo
le due prospettive
di uno stesso oggetto, che riusciamo
a capire cosa stiamo osservando.
Sì, una mela rossa, ma tagliata a metà.
Ed è anche un po' il punto
da cui siamo partite noi:
io riuscivo a vedere una metà della mela,
e Agnese l'altra.
Ma, cosa ne pensi se cerchiamo
di fargli toccare con mano davvero
queste due visioni
e come noi uniamo queste due visioni?
Proviamo.
Allora, vi chiedo
di fare questo esperimento.
Mettetevi nei miei panni,
quelli di una designer che deve scegliere
il materiale migliore per rendere
piu' piacevole un oggetto.
Allora, sicuramente avrete al collo,
o comunque nella vostra borsetta
un cordino come questo.
Vi chiedo di prenderlo in mano, così,
quindi toglietelo dal collo se lo avete,
perfetto.
Poi, vi chiedo di chiudere gli occhi,
no, vi prometto
che non vi lanceremo niente addosso,
fidatevi di noi.
Chiudete gli occhi
e cominciate a far scorrere
tra le vostre mani il cordino.
Ora se ad occhi chiusi vi dovessi chiedere
come descrivereste questo cordino
tra liscio e ruvido, cosa direste?
Bene, molti dicono ruvido.
Se invece, sempre ad occhi chiusi,
vi chiedessi caldo o freddo,
come lo descrivereste?
Ecco, qui siete un po' meno d'accordo.
Ora potete riaprire gli occhi.
L'esperimento però non è finito
perché se vi dovessi chiedere,
per esempio, come giudichereste
alla vista questo cordino,
probabilmente verrebbero fuori
aggettivi diversi e nomi diversi,
magari correlati al suo colore
o alla sua forma,
quindi capite che un designer,
nel momento di scegliere un materiale,
deve tenere in considerazione
le diverse sensazioni
che un materiale potrà restituire.
E, io vi invito a rifare
l'esperimento a casa
e a ripetere magari con altri materiali,
dal legno al vetro o alla plastica,
questo esperimento sia ad occhi aperti
che ad occhi chiusi,
e capirete che ad ogni materiale,
corrisponde una sensazione diversa.
Questo perché i materiali
sono caratterizzati
da differenti proprietà sensoriali.
Adesso tocca a me.
Prego.
Grazie.
Vi chiedo adesso di mettervi
nei miei di panni,
quelli di un ingegnere dei materiali.
Quindi utilizzeremo lo stesso cordino
che avete utilizzato adesso con Agnese
e lo prendiamo dalle due estremità
in questo modo con le mani, ok?
E cerchiamo adesso
di tirarlo come per romperlo.
Attenzione perché vedo in seconda fila
qualcuno che stava dando
una gomitata al vicino.
Ecco. Attenzione al vicino
perché vorremmo
arrivasse alla fine di tutti i TED Talks.
Comunque, tornando a noi,
se adesso io vi chiedessi,
come descrivereste questo materiale,
cosa rispondereste?
Esatto, non rispondereste più liscio,
ruvido, caldo, freddo
come vi ha detto Agnese,
piuttosto resistente,
perché spero che nessuno di voi
l'abbia veramente rotto.
E, oppure, per esempio,
flessibile perché lo pieghiamo così,
in una maniera molto semplice.
Questo è un po'
l'approccio ingegneristico allo studio
e alla valutazione
delle proprietà dei materiali.
E, infatti questo materiale
probabilmente, sarà stato scelto
perché il progettista, chiamiamolo,
non voleva che una volta appeso al collo
il vostro badge vi arrivasse
magari al livello dei piedi.
Come abbiamo capito
da questo breve esperimento,
esistono diversi approcci
allo studio delle stesse proprietà
dei materiali in genere,
però nonostante questi approcci
siano molto diversi, nulla toglie
che non si escludano a vicenda.
Esatto,
quello che cerchiamo tutti i giorni
di fare noi è di combinare
queste due differenti visioni
e punti di vista un po' come succede
nell'intrecciare trama e ordito
per realizzare un tessuto
e, dall'intreccio, appunto,
di queste nostre due visioni,
punti di vista,
capiamo veramente cos'è la molteplicità
delle proprietà dei materiali.
Per estendere, però, questo concetto,
in maniera un po' più ampia,
quello che è importante,
anche se si proviene
da direzioni differenti, e magari opposte,
è trovare un punto in cui incontrarsi
e in cui confrontarsi,
perché alla fine il confronto
è un modo per moltiplicare
le opportunità.
Grazie.
(Applausi)